do you have a Tesla
I'm not a matter of fact I do you do
have a cyber truck
so yeah so do I
yeah you just ain't physically got it
have you paid it in full though
I put a hundred dollars down all right
well still you paid it in full um I
didn't know that you were able to do
that um
you know that's a Ponzi scheme right it
might be this [ __ ] Elon tells
everybody have you seen one like in
person like no
have you yeah we're at here in L.A I
mean you're famous so you get the you
get the end right here
huh how was he uh it's hard it made me
want anymore it's like a Lego block no I
I want it I just what happens is he
takes everybody's money and then he does
a bunch of other [ __ ] with it and then
you wait five years for the car to drop
and he's he's like thanks for the uh
it's how he it's how he like raises
funds
shout out to him you think Elon Musk hey
do you think do you think elon's [ __ ]
up Twitter
I don't know what's going on with it
like I've been seeing some [ __ ] like RP
Twitter what they talking about
like a thousand employees quit
walked out uh there's only like 200
employees left they're saying that you
know what's [ __ ] up is that you could
buy the blue check now
yeah that [ __ ] is so whack yeah it is
because I like I'm like scrolling I'll
see like my friend with like 60
followers now he's verified I'm like bro
you're a [ __ ] nobody
it's kind of like buying a fake Rolex
but then the social media version it's
like yeah you got a blue check but
you're paying eight dollars a month for
it and you live at your mom's house
I know you can pay for uh eight bucks a
month
you're gonna have to start hey you just
put some folks on game everybody in here
get verified right now
hey but even if you have to check
already yeah you got to start paying for
it right
I think I think so
yeah
I don't know about that you had to
maintain your your check I meant elon's
[ __ ] out here I mean you gave him
money for a truck that doesn't even
[ __ ] exist so you know that's nah
that [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
exists I mean yeah like four of them
yeah I like I could get my money back
that's true hey give me that it ain't
gonna give me that how much was it
mine was like one one eighteen you got
the fully loaded yeah yeah with the uh
ATV oh you got the ATV with it yeah good
little camera whatever it is it just
look cool bro this is all this I want in
like 2029 when you finally get it I'll
hit you up and see how it is ain't gonna
be that long you might get yours
you're at the top of the list because
you cast your [ __ ] out yeah